80 million years ago during the
Cretaceous Period Dinosaurs Ruled the
Korean Peninsula the same way they ruled
the rest of the Earth at that time the
part of the land now known as gionam
yosu was the forest habitat of numerous
dinosaur species among them is the
Tarbosaurus the Ferocious Hunters of the
forest in a monologue a young
Tarbosaurus named Speckles says that he
was born on the night of the full moon a
curious and playful child Speckles lives
with his older brother twin sisters and
mother the family's Nest sits Atop A
Mountain where they can see the whole
Forest clearly they live happily
spending time together hunting and
chasing herbivorous species of dinosaurs
but since Speckles is only a year old he
is yet to learn about killing prey
during the Hunts though he notes Down
The Killing tactics used by his older
siblings his elder brother is the one
who chases the prey while the other two
siblings Ambush it Speckles is excited
to use these tactics during his practice
as well but when his Training Day
finally arrives it marks the beginning
of a long and painful journey into
adulthood for him on that day Mom is
ready to teach Speckles how to kill prey
when suddenly the earth below them
starts trembling it is the result of a
massive Stampede of dinosaurs caused by
a T-Rex the mightiest predator of them
all because he's missing an eye everyone
addresses him as one eye during the
chaos little Speckles and his siblings
start running towards safety but they
are eventually separated his elder
brother dies after getting stepped on by
some dinosaurs while the twin sisters
are thrown off the cliff right then mom
also arrives but she's a few seconds
late only Speckles remains alive out of
her four children sadly she doesn't even
get the time to grieve as one eye
arrives and attacks her mom fights for a
while with all of her might but is
easily overpowered this gives the
vicious Tyrannosaurus the upper hand so
he throws her off the cliff she thuds
against the Rocks a couple of times
before finally falling down to her death
mean while Speckles tearfully watches
his mother die from afar now he is alone
and has nowhere to go he doesn't even
know how to hunt but still he vows to
avenge his family one day in the next
scene we see the little tarbissar
Scavenging and raiding nests for fear of
starvation he steals an egg from a
pterosaur a flying reptile and satisfies
his hunger but unfortunately the reptile
arrives and starts chasing after him
Speckles almost gets killed but he
manages to get away by diving into a
river later while Sheltering himself in
a shed Speckles hears a herd of
Velociraptors chasing prey Velociraptors
are small-sized carnivores who are
feared for their agility and viciousness
Speckles follows them discreetly only to
learn that the prey has been captured by
none other than the T-Rex one eye we
learn that one eye is usurped Speckles
his home and he nests there as king of
the jungle desperate for food Speckles
sneaks inside and attempts to steal some
meat but gets caught by one eye
fortunately he manages to run away
without getting attacked the movie then
skips several years later Speckles is
now five but he is still too young to
avenge his family's death in the
meantime one eye continues to kill and
rule the jungle one day a deadly battle
erupts between two horned dinosaurs they
are fighting to assert their Authority
on the females of the area after a while
one of them loses and he is kicked out
of their group this is the perfect
opportunity for one eye to Target his
prey and what better prey than the
caucasaurus but when he follows the
horned dinosaur another giant Predator
interrupts him this Predator has
razor-sharp claws that can slice through
even bone however the T-Rex is not going
to give up so easily he uses his
intelligence and manages to trick the
Predator into getting his claws stuck in
a tree one eye then grabs him by the
neck and kills him all this is being
observed by a frightened Speckles from
nearby after a while as one eye is
munching on his fresh kill a female
Tarbosaurus named blue eye suddenly
appears and decides to steal his food
but when she realizes how Territorial
and threatening one eye is she quickly
runs away meanwhile Speckles manages to
steal a piece of food from one eye the
female Tarbosaurus follows him and out
of pity he offers her a piece of meat
because of this kind of gesture blue
eyes also opens up and the two become
fast friends now they hunt and survive
together the scene then cuts to five
years later again Speckles and blue eyes
have relocated far away from one eye
they hunt together as Speckles chases
the prey While Blue Eyes ambushes it
this is a trick he learned from his
deceased siblings in this way the two
become Inseparable and start living
happily however one day one eye
discovers their hunting ground and again
attempts to usurp their territory at
first he attacks blue eyes and injures
her this enrages Speckles and he
attempts to take revenge but to no avail
he is still no match for the Powerful
Beast as a result he decides to find
another way and eventually comes up with
a play without wasting any time he lures
one eye to a swamp and traps him there
because the soil is very loose he slowly
starts drowning seeing this Speckles and
blue eyes celebrate their Victory but
little do they realize that one eye is a
persistent Beast he shows up right
behind them ready to finish them off
fortunately Speckles and blue eyes
manage to escape in the nick of time a
few days later we see that the pair has
once again moved from their territory
hoping to flee from one eye as far away
as possible they walk tirelessly for
days but there are no signs of Life
nearby blue eyes even fall sick and
decides that she cannot go any further
but just then speckle spots a large herd
of friendly dinosaurs leading somewhere
he stretches himself to see a hot spring
beneath the Rocky Mountains this is the
hope that the pair needed so they
quickly help themselves to the hot
spring and relax in the water Ten Years
Later the pair has made a home in a New
Forest far away from the old one
Speckles is now a 20 year old young and
robust male he can easily corner and
kill his prey he is also waiting to
reproduce babies with blue eyes what are
you waiting for cowboy unfortunately
their happiness is cut short when the
vicious T-Rex again shows up one day he
is still determined to kill the couple
for good he cunningly throws a rock at
them from above and while Speckles
attempts to save blue eyes he is thrown
into the sea following this one eye
jumps down with his thundering Roar and
begins attacking blue eyes she puts up a
good fight but it is not enough one eye
then grabs her by the neck ready to
finish her off once and for all
thankfully by this time Speckles shows
up and defends his injured mate seeing
Blue Eyes On The Ground makes him
remember his mother's murder scene so
not wanting to see history repeat itself
he gathers all his might and attacks the
T-Rex surprisingly after a grueling duel
he manages to throw one eye to the
ground and make him leave this elates
Speckles as he has finally defeated his
old Nemesis after the victory he
reclaims his old family nest and hunting
grants the couple then decides to hatch
their eggs there the procedure is very
intense as for a month blue eyes has to
give 24 7 guard to the hatchlings
unfortunately because of the difficult
environment only three little Bobbies
make it one of the babies looks just
like Speckles with spots all over his
body hence the parents decide to name
him Speckles Jr well no one ever said
dinosaurs were creative as time passes
by the Cretaceous Period nears its end
there is a change in the environment as
the days are getting warmer nearby water
streams begin to vaporize and the
surroundings get drier day by day most
of the herbivorous dinosaurs are having
a hard time finding fresh food one
afternoon the children suddenly cry for
help but Speckles and blue eyes are too
busy to notice any threat in the
surrounding area suddenly a strong
earthquake hits the ground causing the
nearby active volcano to erupt huge
balls of fire are thrown from the
volcano which begin to destroy the
forest this terrorizes all the dinosaurs
and their forced to flee from their
territory everything around them seems
to be falling apart during the disaster
Speckles and his family travel through a
shortcut tunnel when suddenly the rocks
and debris Begin to Fall From Above
sadly one of the children is hit by a
huge ball of rock killing him
immediately that better not have been
Speckles Junior damn it when blue eyes
goes to save her other children another
piece of debris Falls hitting her in the
leg she is seriously wounded and cannot
even walk properly after this speckles
in the family join with other migratory
herds of dinosaurs fleeing the natural
disaster two weeks into the journey
there is no sign of water or life only a
vast desert of nothingness without food
or water most of them become exhausted
from the long walk so one by one they
begin to collapse onto the ground this
is the perfect opportunity for the
carcass eating Velociraptors who often
hunt in packs and prey on the weakest
suddenly a large herbivorous dinosaur
falls to the ground from exhaustion he
is soon surrounded by a heard of
Velociraptors who are ready to munch on
their new prey sadly blue eyes also
cannot walk anymore because of her leg
injuries Speckles realizes his mate
could suffer the same fate as the
herbivorous dinosaur so he encourages
her to get up however blue eyes is too
weak to stand so she gives up she then
urges Speckles to take the children and
save themselves meanwhile the
Velociraptors noticed the weakened blue
eyes and to decide to prey on her next
speckle stands his ground and kills a
few of them but with every passing
second he becomes more and more
exhausted to make matters worse the
Velociraptors also noticed speckles's
two kids and go after them in the
meantime blue eyes become so weak that
she cannot even breathe anymore she
slowly closes her eyes and bids a
sorrowful goodbye to her family in the
next scene Speckles Mourns for his wife
but he soon realizes that they do not
have much time so he carries his
children and escapes the Velociraptors
after arriving at a safe location he and
the kids look back and watch the evil
creatures Feast on Blue Eyes a
devastated Speckles only says I'm sorry
I don't know what I expected from a
dinosaur movie but this is dark as balls
two weeks later the herd finally has
some respite in the distance they see a
large fertile area where there is
endless food and shelter for everyone
however the path to the green Oasis is
very dangerous they have to cross a
narrow Edge that surrounds the mountains
and beneath them is a never-ending deep
sea despite this the herd including
Speckles and his two children slowly
moves forward hoping to reach the Oasis
and start a new life meanwhile we see
one eye cautiously watching The Herd
from above a mountain as Speckles and
his kids are moving through the Narrow
Path suddenly there is a stampede of
dinosaurs coming towards them this
triggers speckles's childhood memories
where a similar Stampede killed his
siblings and to his surprise he once
again encounters one eye who has been
driven out by the same natural disaster
it is then revealed that just like he
did before one eye has initiated the
Stampede in order to Ambush Speckles and
his family once again the two giant
beasts come face to face in what turns
out to be an intense battle when one eye
starts losing he decides to go after
speckles's children the latter tries his
best to save the kids but unfortunately
one of them is killed filled with
vengeance Speckles attacks one eye and
manages to thut him into the ground
however the resilient T-Rex stands right
back up and throws Speckles Jr off of a
cliff and into the ocean no Speckles
Junior no oh you're gonna pay he then
begins to Corner Speckles just like he
did to his mother however our hero
Tarbosaurus gains the upper hand and
manages to throw the T-Rex off the cliff
after this he looks down and sees that
his son is still alive screaming for
help at the same time he also sees one
eye alive and heading towards the kid
the sights scares Speckles so he
immediately dives into the sea to save
his last surviving son meanwhile we see
the kid hanging by his life with the
support of submerged wood just when one
eye is about to grab him Speckles
attacks the old beast from behind the
duo once again Brawl for a while and are
injured during the process due to the
smell of blood in the water we see a
pair of water dinosaurs also called
Tylosaurus heading towards them Speckles
realizes this and worries about his son
who is alone and vulnerable in the water
after a long fight in the ocean he
eventually manages to overpower one eye
and throw him off to the Tylosaurus this
finally kills the vicious T-Rex once and
for all after a while Speckles reunites
with his son and heads towards the
distant Oasis the path is very long and
tedious but he doesn't want to give up
unfortunately a few hours later his eyes
get tired and eventually close just when
it appears as if the father-son duo has
been killed in the next scene we learned
that they have somehow made it to the
shore Speckles lays unconscious on the
beach and opens his eyes when he hears
his son desperately calling for him in
the closing monologue Speckles wishes a
peaceful happy life for his son in this
newfound lush jungle subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching